We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine to David p here
is a caller asking why won't I talk about
left wing racism?
Hi David.
Oh, first color.
I was just wondering if you could, um, talk
about something that really is concerning,
which is the raising some of the left.
Okay.
Um,
yeah, and it gets cut off there.
Tell me what left doing racism you want me
to talk about?
I mean, listen, I've talked about a comments
from supposedly leftists who tweet things
like, I will not vote for any white or male
candidate.
Uh, in 2020.
I believe that is a discriminatory comment
and I've called it out.
Uh, and the person who tweeted that tried
to get me fired from my adjunct teaching position
that I had, uh, last year at Boston College.
Uh, I've talked about antisemitism on the
left.
So I have no problem talking about racism
on the left to the extent that it exists.
And it does, although it is different and
not as significant as racism on the right,
but it exists and I talk about it, uh, but
tell me exactly what racism it is you want
me to address and I will gladly do it.
On today's bonus show, we will talk about
an FDA warning that drinking bleach will not
cure cancer or autism.
Yes, this is something that is spreading in
pseudo science communities.
We will talk about a Trump administration
rule, which would penalize immigrants for
needing benefits and availing themselves of
those benefits and much, much more.
Two ways to get access to the bonus show.
Number one, become a member@wwwdotjoinpacman.com
number two, become a [inaudible]
patron at patrion.com/david Pakman show.
The show doesn't have to end now because the
bonus show is coming up.
Next.
If you remember the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.